et
tu restes combien de temps 48 heures sur
part lundi matin
et
ans
je souhaite que l'échangé butler en fait
tout est sûre on m'arrête tes conneries
c'est moi qui ait la garde
tu vas me la sortie la gamine avec cette
affaire va nulle part si toi elle est
toujours tout seul moi je vais la mer
j'ai pas le choix tu vas me sortez la
gamine à regret avec moi mais je suis
pas sûr que le juge cette fois ci
aillent dans votre sens si vous ne
changez pas votre organisation niveau du
travail
c'est vraiment important pour vraiment
que sur ce terrain si tu fais un point
c'est pas la peine de revenir quand
quelqu'un d'autre
c'est aussi quelque chose je veux c'est
un petit bateau pour justement être là
tous les jours avec mon gars
avoir un minimum de vie de famille tu
fasses beaux sites nautiques pour le
faire un bien comme il faut
je me fais confiance oui